I feel like this there's a tongue draped
over my hand right now I've never tried
uni before I love sushi I never had that
my only experience with sea urchins is
like finding Nemo and Freddy to fish my
dad loves sushi and he says that sea
urchin is the worst thing he's ever
eaten
it's not what I imagined oh oh it looks
like a tongue it looks like our brain
feels like a slug it's just like ripping
okay always want to try it I'm gonna do
it up some sand in there
suction out that bag God what's the big
deal about it like it was fine
tastes like a combination between the
ocean and shoe leather that like intense
sea taste made my stomach turn I can
feel it going down my esophagus the
texture was like if a toddler's himself
I think it has that kind of like muddy
texture to it but the flavors very mild
I'm very cheap so I don't know if I
would pay for this but it's good enough
to eat if someone bought it for me once
you get past the diarrhea color and tone
texture it's not bad at all
no I always eat animals and then I get I
feel sorry for them afterwards like I
don't know why this happens to me